vice president Mike Pence has formally
filed papers to run for president in
2024. he has not announced it yet an
announcement now almost certainly will
come because according to the federal
government at least Mike Pence is a
candidate for president a lot of people
are rolling their eyes a lot of people
saying Mike Pence has no shot a lot of
people are asking why is he doing this
he's not polling very high the Trump
people don't like him anymore The
Establishment people don't like him
because he worked for Trump the Trump
people don't like him because he
wouldn't wield his power to try to delay
the certification of the 2020 election
he's a man without a country he's in no
man's land right now yeah
maybe he is Pence is is thinking right
now look my political career is not
looking so bright for the future because
of what happened at the end of the Trump
Administration so might as well throw my
hat in now